[Music]
hello hi everyone
today I would like to continue my
previous lecture
making decisions and
complex positions
during the game
you have
many
moments when you need
to make
decision
and uh last time
we
finished our lecture in this position
after Bishop B1 this was my game from
U.S Senior championship
2022 versus Grandmaster Larry
Christensen I was trying to create
Fortress here with 93 pound
before
and again three
it was
a
we can like it possible to create
Fortress but after Bishop F1 I didn't
find
good opportunity and here I needed to
make
the most critical decision in the game
uh
unfortunately
I played F4 here and after this move
position is absolutely
lost
black plate can F5 as I
apparent last time I can have two in
this position was bad because of King G4
and black
against penetrates
and thought a wise camp and our white is
lost here because he is
wasn't uh
before pound
so I played F4 instead
and after I can take a kidney F5
I played I can F2 probably more stubborn
uh
was 94 here but anyway after Bishop
there is G2
Knight D6
Keen F6
if you can E6 then there is a double
attack
Knight 98 and now pound on G7 scan game
and also Knight C7 is a thread
so
you can F6
B5 white is trying uh
to trade pounds on the queen side
But Here There is a very strong move
kidney six
Knight eight days B5
and uh in this position
again white has choice between Knight G7
1987
check and Knight C7 but unfortunately
both are moves cannot
help save the game for white for example
after Knight takes G7
black and play can F6 Knight takes H5
King G6
Knight strip
the only move
is G4 but after F5
uh black has been G4 pound
and
with support on B and G files uh White
Knight
you cannot do anything
uh
to help
save
the game uh
for example after Knight G3 ft G4
white can try
to fight but Bishop C6 and this position
is lost
the rest can be
uh can be four can a six
Bishop 8 King G4
Bishop C6
and now uh
black I lost the temper but after a king
D4 King G6
uh he is already a black king has ready
to help to be pound
again not just three Bishop P6 and a
position is lost
also after
uh
Knight C7
instead of
an attack G7
black is winning end game with three
pounds on the king side versus two
pounds the kill side because of very
strong
H4 opportunity after GTX H4 context F4
collection
also H Bound for example Knight G6 here
H4
simply G6
Bishop F3
and uh
black audience
a pound on H4
ruins the game
so
so even ah
most of our move for Knight E4 or cannot
help in this position
so I played King F2
Bishop B5 the paneling is lost here
because black has
two more extra temples
Focus bounce
uh moves F6 G6 F5 and a black can always
win in a position
after King F3 uh Bishop C6 skin S3
black is simply brilliant
potion has passed on the skin side first
F6 you can F2 G5 here even doesn't need
to capture pound and G2 Helen some
chances for a draw after B5 before B5
ah
and after G5
after hd5 ft G5 kina3 again F5 now uh
White is in socks one
and uh it's impossible
to
keep all
squares under control uh
G4 E4 F4 and uh black is winning here
but in the position
I gave you
as
homework
white head and
amazing opportunity to make a draw here
and to create the real Fortress
in the game I was unable to build this
Fortress but in this position
white has
such opportunity
uh
did anybody that
find this
way
yes robust G4 this excellent opportunity
and amazing resource
white could make a draw
after G4 G3 to G4
and what this idea of this move
on the first side it's unclear why G4
could lead to draw
but let's
look at this position
first of all uh White's idea
is
to uh
have a G4 a square occupied by a black
pound after which black king cannot
penetrate on the Keen side
through G4 Square for example after HD
G4
white plays F4 kin F5 G3 and now you see
that all squares
on the fifth rank are and whites
business control
and now this is a fortress and even
if a black tries to break this Fortress
G5
F takes G5 Kinte G5
it's enough for the white to put his
Knight on F4 he can play Knight E4 check
but also Knight D5
leads to a draw and black you cannot
make any progress for example I've taken
F5 kin goes to D4 and then white can
simply
a weight uh putting his Knight on F4 and
he has
enough squares for the night
and there is no any suggest one white
can go from a photo H5 if a black Bishop
will not be on F1 then G2 Square E2 G3
D5
there are many squares for white Knights
our White Knight and black cannot break
this Fortress but uh
so G4 was very nice shot but a black has
another options here why he should
take on G4
Helen White to build the Fortress he can
play
Bishop takes G2 instead
now this uh another
uh
option for black to play for a win but
here white can play F4 check can F6 and
G takes H5
and it seems that uh
back again
I cannot do anything
for example
after taking a six
or let's
start with again F5
White
I can use his
a b pound
so they were breaking to the queen side
and after that white can start Play
against black pounds on the king side
let's look B5
now a takes B5 uh
doesn't help because after Knight takes
B5 King G4 Knight G6
white is just on time to attack G7 pound
Bishop
D5
98 and a white uh
either
a
thread
G7 for H5 pound with a draw or after G6
G6 is even the password well because of
H6
so often a kin takes H5 Knight takes G7
it's easy draw
so it takes B5
is not an option
uh
black should try A5
and now B6
and let's look how uh White can create
threats to the black spawns on the king
side
for example after Bishop eight he can
play Knight B5
King G4
Knight C7 Bishop C6
Knight eight and now
the king white king is in the square of
a pound and White Knight
he has time to capture black pounds on
the king side
in case
of
kinesics
here
again Knight B5
after King G7
a white case a very strong
continuation F5 now F6 is a Serial and
if black plays F6 then Knight can attack
a G7 pound
through E6 Square
for example A4
in G3 Bishop D5
against three
H3
and now simply 96
and a white
I cannot
I lost here because here corrects the G7
pound
and this draw
if uh instead of King G7 A4 then
whitekins is going to the square of a
four pound
and here
again
F6 or can F5 let's start the skn F5 it
doesn't help because of Knight D6 Knight
takes
F7 King G4 and simply H6
Trading
pounds on the key inside and I can draw
instead of
getting F5 where you can start with F6
move but anyway it does help you can CS3
can F5
King G4 and again
white is on time
G7 pound
again a white
is able to make a draw here
so it seems that this position after GTX
H5 is a draw
so Bishop
digital
does help to win but black has a very
strong
chance to play H4 here
what to do in this position
and suddenly
white can create
another real Fortress he can play
F4 check here
King G6
now can F2
Bishop C4
and here G3
so what
is a fortune a black pound is to trade
in G3 after which uh it will be
The Fortress with
again all squares
on the uh all control squares on the
fifth rank
I responds on B4 F4 and Knight on C3
and in case of H3
uh breaks idea is to create
uh stress
after uh
for example F6 then he can try
to put his Bishop first on G2 and when
white will be in six one and uh
and uh King
is on G1 then attack Pawn on G4 after
Bishop F3 and after that uh black can
break the Fortress but the white has
G5 power now G5 move now
and again there is a fortress
on the board
let's look after Bishop P6 simply King
G1 now
uh black I can do nothing
because
white can simply play Akin H2
a king G1
a virgin after a bishop D5
King H2 o
again
wise ideas to capture the spawn and if a
black
tries to
protect it with the
Bishop then I can
cover the last Square
F5
sorry
F5 with G power
and after G4 uh it's easy draw because
now white I can simply wait uh King G3
kin H2 and black cannot make any
progress
so after G5
there is a real fortress on the board
and black cannot win the game and it was
the pity that
I didn't find this uh excellent
opportunity to make a draw
when
the draw was so close
and you see how important to make
correct decision in the position
where you have
a choice
so
and now I would like to show you another
game and play it in
the same tournament in U.S Senior
championship
foreign
thank you
uh
I played uh with white this game I was
played
uh in the last round of the tournament
and uh
real Benjamin played with black
and we started
as a Korean Queens Indian
B6
G3 Bishop A6 B3
Bishop before check Bishop J2
Bishop E7 Bishop G2
that's quite popular
system
and black
uh often use the system in his play
Castle queso nature three
Bishop B7 the usual plan here for white
is to play Rook C1 or queen C2
then Bishop F4
uh
in Black
often play with
King and pounds after C5 DTX C5 Orvis
isolated the d-bound taken back on C5
for
the piece with the Knight for example
and uh
black
often use this
setup
to play for a win
[Music]
one of the main
positions here is
to
play with a white Bishop on B2 and also
that position
can be
you can get this position with bishop
and B to from a different opinions uh
Bishop C1 looks like wasting time but
after
Knight B7 or night
A6 and Bishop B2 uh if you get the usual
position because black wasted time for
Bishop before and
there's a before check Bishop p7 back
and Bishop A6 Bishop B7 back so he lost
two temples and white also lost two
tempers for Bishop G2 Bishop C1 Bishop
B2 and uh
if you've got the usual position
from Burger Indian
defense
with Bishop B7 instead of Bishop A6 and
this is also possible Bishop B2 and
instead of playing with hanging or
isolated upon D5 or hanging upon G5 and
C5
gel decided
to play the center he played Knight E4
and his setup probably to trade Knights
and then to put his Bishop on G6 let's
play qina 7 and trying to play on the
king side
so here I need to decide what to do Roxy
one
is a usual move but what to do after
Knight takes history
now what his
different plans first plan
is
to capture
ancestry with the Rook
then
playing Queen C1 and trying to trade
dark Square Bishop Bishop's
after Bishop H3
actually
it is a quite
useful for white to trade dark Square
Bishops in this position
uh to uh we can C7
a pound
and uh
if white is able to trade dark Square
Bishops then uh black will be forced to
push his Pawn to C6 or to C5
uh engagen
positions which could be better for
white
so what to do uh what is better uh
to capture ancestry reviews Rogue or
with Bishop
I decided to take with the bishop with
another plan
to play maybe before
to prevent C5 move
and also uh
white is still ready to play on the
queen side so I played I took on
Accessory with the bishop
after OCTA AC3
Bishop G6 Queen C1
Rook is
white is trying uh
to use his plan and cleaner 7
prevention Bishop S3 and now white
can start with Knight E5
probably a
uh this position was slightly better for
white
after Knight takes E5 for example
Trading
the pounds
Rook takes
cs7
but anyway black
has good chances to equalize
he can play either Roxette Rock a to
seed or Bishop A6 attacking E2 pound
and position
is approximately equal here
however white could try
to play for a win because of other Pawn
the final position
and uh
slight chances to get some
advantage
but I decided
to take once yesterday with a bishop
Arrow K8
95 immediately probably
it was better to play
a plan this before like uh
I intended to play uh after Bishop takes
history
and after before
Bishop G6
rookie one or S3 Knight F's 6 94 Bishop
B2 and uh
white is ready to play on the queen side
appropriate to play E3 then maybe Rook
E2 Rock E2
Rook E2 to C2
95
trying to put his Knight on C6
or Knight G3 so white is slightly better
in the center and black
should wait for wides play
so but I
started with Knight E5 here Knight takes
E5 is quite dangerous because upon D5
uh
it's vulnerable uh for black and if
black
protects it with C6
move then E4 can be very strong so after
95
black plate Bishop G6
again Queen C2
it's not so good to
take pound on E5 Knight takes E5 GTX E5
Bishop takes E5 because pound on E7 is
hanging
and after that the pound on G5 will be
weak so black
played negative six
Rook fg1
and A5 it's very important a move
prevention before and that's why
probably uh White I should start his
play on The Queen side with B3 to before
move
after A5
uh
I I need to change
my plan
and here probably
uh it should be to put my knight on G3
playing my B3 somewhere and
trying to play B3 to B4
trading the pounds and
at the end also trading dark Square
Bishops begin C7
power
so I started here with E3
Green Seed Knight G3 Knight E4
Bishop A1
uh White is ready to play before ajin
like to give
a black to trade he's not for the large
Square Bishop because my plane uh is
before and to trade dark Square Bishops
uh
that's quite a white Bishop for a dark
Square black Bishop
because Bishop G6 is protection C7
Square so I played Bishop A1 and now
foreign
started
very interesting attack
there is a question why before so
important here
uh
as I said uh
that before is important that because I
need to trade dark Square Bishops so we
can C7 Square
that's why white is trying to play B4
eight days before Bishop takes before
after that pound on C7 will be weak and
you can create
stress to weak black pounds
but uh
awaiting for this preparing for this
before move a black starting a very nice
attack
with Knight G5 move and here
was another
position where I needed
to make
a correct decision
what is Black's idea
the main his idea to put his Queen on G4
and then play Knight F3
uh creation stress to the king and also
try and to trade
his Knight for the light Square Bishops
so weak because light Square Bishop
light squares around white king are very
weak
and the light Square Bishop is the only
piece which protects all those squares
so here I needed to decide whether Queen
G4 uh
continuing with Knight F3 is
a strong threat or I need a to prevent
uh this plan and it seems that H4
prevention this attack
ing G4 Knight F3 was uh more precise
here and after H4 Knight E4 or let's
start with 96 before it is before
Bishop takes before
Queen G7 and here white can start with
Knight C6
and
black pounds on the queen side can be
weak here
also if
after H4
black plays Knight E4
and then before is also
a very strong Awakening black pounds on
the
Queen side
after eight days before Bishop takes
before uh
Knight on F4 uh
break nothing for yes placed even worse
because it's not protecting C7
in a square
so
probably H4 uh in this position
ah these are serious attention but I
took my decision to play before
immediately because I thought that I
will
have enough time
to defend my kin
uh
and to create weaknesses on the queen
side at the same time
so I played I started this before
green G4
now what to do
of course white could try to play here
can H1
in this idea Knight F3 H3
attacking the queen
H5 and clean it to again but uh
in this case white is simply a wasting
time so
I calculated variation uh B takes A5
Knight F3
take on F3 Queen and take F3 and now our
I realized that I missed a very
important
a move
for example after ethics B6
I was going uh
to play after a bishop C8 Bishop B4
but uh
no no after eight takes B6 uh Bishop C8
Bishop B4 Bishop is not possible because
of Bishop takes before Knight takes
before uh Bishop H3 but my idea was to
play Bishop's C3 and I I missed uh
Bishop F5 move very strong move after
which
ah black queens exchange here
Bishop H3
is not
a good opportunity because of Knight E1
but after Bishop F5 uh White cannot do
anything here Bishop E4 is a thread
and if Knight E1 then black simply
capture Queen on C2 then
uh after night the accessory Bishop
takes D1 and black events material
but and here after
getting this position I need to uh
make another decision which was critical
what to do
also
after eight takes B6
because of
Bishop F5
so I missed the
this opportunity
and uh
now I needed to make decision uh how
to save the game
uh
Knight F4 suggested by robust is not
working because black simply captured
on F4 with the Bishop from G6 as in
Bishop H3 is winning
so in this position also uh it was
a possibility to play a queen bit too
but now uh instead of Bishop C8 Bishop
before this idea knighter one black case
very good attack
of the H5
and if Bishop before then simply take
take
91 you can F5
and here
look uh how strong is
a blacks attack for example The Rook
takes C7
black and
play Rook takes A2
and here Knight G3 protection F2 pound
queen F3
The Rock on Giovannis Kenyan green B1
and H4
what to do after rugby 7 H3 is winning
because
there is no Knight F4
a move
Knight F4 then uh screen takes F2
if Kinect one here
then
green H1 checkmate
again so what
has to capture pound on H4 but after
this
Queen G4 check and Bishop A6
uh
black gets very strong attack
so what to do what decision
to make
and here
unfortunately I didn't
calculate uh the variation I intended to
play
plane before until the very end
uh
it seems that
a takes B6 was possible to play
but I needed to find
very nice
opportunity
for white
Bishop C8
now the threat is Bishop H3
I mean so I I need to move my Bishop
from a one
and the best move was Bishop before as I
intended to play
uh when I played B4 but why this move is
possible
here Bishop days before Knight days
before black wins after Bishop H3
so what
uh White can do here why Bishop before
is good move here
can you find
explanation why
white can play Bishop before here
it turns out that after a bishop before
Bishop
takes before
now or Bishop F5 is not working here
white can simply trade Bishop
he can capture Bishop takes G6 and after
in Bishop F4
there is no check made because White
is ready to run with the King and after
she takes G6 Kina one
is safe and he has two extra pounds on
the queen side
so
Bishop F5
is about here
in this position but what to do after
the bishop takes before night is before
lost immediately and suddenly
White
has
B7 move
this intermediate move
is helping to
defend all squares now if black plays
Bishop H3 then after Knight F4
the square G2 is protected
the bishop industry is hanging the pound
on B7 is Kenyan so
after Knight F4 white is simply uh
winning here
for example after Rook takes
Rock A to B and taken on B7
white I can win another pound
here of the queen takes H7
and white has
two extra pounds and I've been in
position
so
Bishop H3
is bad
here what to do
Bishop F5 is also bad because
black does have
a Time
to
give Checkmate after beat days
Queen
Rook takes
and
white winds here because
The Rook is hanging
Rock takes A2 here
this idea Bishop H3 and attacking a
pound on F2
uh
rotates it does help
can you find why
please write in the chat if you need
okay grenade Bishop f8
and now Bishop H3 is very strong thread
what to do
roxy7
as possible but I can play Bishop H3
and black
is better
yeah you can play like in takes F7
immediately right
can takes F7
and uh there is a fork Knight F5 Knight
F3
uh winning the game
uh if a black plays rockafade here then
white can simply capture the bishop
and Bishop H3
uh
is not good because of Queen takes D5
I can protect G2 Square from D5 and if
Bishop E4 then again what
give an extra rope
I can simply
around with the key
one and a white a wins here
so
black
has the
divert his Bishop
from H3 Square Bishop takes B7
not before
uh Bishop said back
and what to do now
there is a threat at Bishop H3
uh Knight G3 here
then uh black yes restaurant move for
Bishop F5
I guess I get Bishop E4
and again Knight one
is uh is worse for white because of
Bishop takes
C2 win exchange and
the
exposition
should be much better
so what to do in this position
what has defense out of Bishop H3
6
also but because of Bishop F5
26 attacking Roxanne E8 and 8
but black can play Bishop F5
and queen takes D5
does help because of Bishop E4
I win the game
so uh what a white can do here
and in this position it's not necessary
to attack deep pound from C6
what
you can play Queen B3
now or Bishop H3 a white has green takes
D5 move
but what to do after
Bishop F5
this idea
Bishop E4
can you find
the defense
character
react
for uh five more
Bishop before is very strong straight
takes D5 doesn't work but white has an
excellent idea
nice Knight D5 is also bad because of
Bishop E4
95 would be okay after Bishop S3 Knight
F4 but uh Bishop E4 wins
and white has an excellent idea E4
after A4 uh what is trading queens
getting slightly a better position for
example at the
Bishop takes E4
giving takes F3
foreign
white is slightly better because his
bounds
uh
protected and it's not so easy to defend
the C7 and D5 pounds
for example
uh
after uh before Roku 3
White
the pound on C7 is gangan also F3
might be a thread
also a white can defend his upon
more into history
and white is slightly better probably
black has good chances
uh
for a draw but
White
should play this way
so my first intention was correct uh
but here
white should play
a text B6
this idea
before and then B7
in the game
I made
a bad decision I played Bishop CS3 and
here a black
uh
and got very good
chances
for Attack on the king side because now
White
light squares are very weak
so in the game it was played B takes
A5 Knight F1 gain H5
and black has very strong Bishops Bishop
on G6 cannot be traded now on light
Square Bishop is going to join attack
either through a sixth square or through
C7 or C8
and uh I was not able
to hold this position
uh Bishop P2 is a threat so I played F3
aruki 6 take Rook gate and agile found
the excellent idea uh to create Western
attack on the king
Roxy 3 protection is three pound
but he found F5
a move this idea F4
opening up either e file or G file for
his Rooks for example if the it is F4 it
will be Rook E2 thread after GTX F4
uh
a g file uh is also open for the his row
after Knight G2
even after uh negative a black played F4
and a white position is hopeless
for example if I take GTX F4 black can
continue
six this screen takes F3 thread uh
for example Bishop takes C7 Queen takes
F3
and now
after okay one because eruct H2 is a
thread
and also after
hurricane
Bishop B4 is possible
if
what it takes on G6 then simply Bishop
it to minion
so
here after Queen F2 instead of Bishop
takes C7 black wins obvious uh
Bishop F4 and uh
after he takes E4 uh Rook E2 are we in
the queen
so I applied can F2 but the position is
absolutely lost here G5 black queens
a knight
and uh
in a few moves again I finished
because Vice position is completely lost
so you see how important to make correct
decision in the critical position
one
incorrect move can lead
to the last of the game
and uh
thank you for joining me for this
lecture
and I hope that
I yes I thought here how to make a
decision and uh
in critical positions could be useful
for you in your games
[Music]